¿Imaginas un país que regara las plantas
con agua salada? ¿Un país que haya conseguido
transformar un árido y estéril desierto
en frondosos campos de cultivo? ¿Un país
que situado en uno de los lugares más áridos
y secos de la tierra haya sido capaz de hacerse
con un suministro casi ilimitado de agua?
Pues queridos amigos, amigas, no se trata
de ningún espejismo, ese lugar existe.
Gran parte de su territorio se asienta sobre
los desiertos de Neguev y de Judea y su nombre
es Israel.
Hablamos del único país de todo el planeta
Tierra que hoy tiene menos superficie de desierto
que hace 50 años.
Por si fuera poco, cada año el país exporta
más de 2.000 millones de dólares en productos
agrícolas, sobre todo productos frescos,
como frutas y vegetales.
Y sobre esto es exactamente de lo que os vamos
a hablar en este vídeo, sobre cómo Israel
ha sido capaz de convertir al mismo desierto
en un vergel, sobre cómo este país ha superado
la escasez del agua.
Por cierto, este vídeo lo hemos preparado
gracias a la comunidad de Patreon. Allí es
dónde se escogió precisamente este tema.
Así que está especialmente dedicado a todos
los que nos apoyais en Patreon.
Arranquemos.
(Un informe confidencial del Consejo Nacional
de Inteligencia de los Estados Unidos publicado
en 2012 y más tarde desclasificado parcialmente
apuntaba a una futura crisis hídrica: una
enorme crisis del agua a nivel mundial.
Según este informe el consumo de agua se
situaría por encima de cualquier parámetro
sostenible. Cada vez somos más y cada vez
gastamos más agua. Consumimos más carne,
tenemos más jardines, más piscinas y consumimos
más energía.)
Todo ello, son cosas que podéis creerme requieren
de muchísima agua.
Por ejemplo, producir un kilo, tan sólo un
kilo de carne consume 17 veces más agua que
producir un kilo de maíz.
De esta forma el informe coincidía con otras
informaciones de expertos en que más del
20% de la población mundial, más de 1.500
millones de personas, sufrirán y mucho con
esta crisis hídrica durante las próximas
décadas.
1.500 millones de personas que tendrán serios,
pero que muy serios problemas para acceder
a un suministro regular de agua.
Hablamos, amigos, de una crisis que pondría
en jaque todo el sistema alimentario mundial
y que no penséis ni por un instante que se
limitaría a castigar a los países más pobres.
Por ejemplo, el Valle de San Joaquín en California,
el centro, el corazón de la agricultura de
calidad californiana podría desaparecer,
al menos tal y como hoy lo conocemos.
Y eso, eso ha hecho que en este vídeo nos
hagamos una pregunta: ¿estamos acaso condenados
a no tener suficiente agua?
Pues, queridos, amigos, amigas, creo que ha
llegado el momento de echar un vistazo a uno
de los lugares más áridos y yermos de toda
la tierra.
(Ni más ni menos que el 60% del territorio
israelí está cubierto por el desierto, lo
que explica que la relación de este pueblo
con el agua sea tan estrecha, que está está
presente constantemente, ya sea en la cultura,
la política o, incluso, en la religión.
De hecho, una de las oraciones judías más
conocidas, el Shema, advierte que el castigo
por no cumplir los mandamientos de Dios será,
precisamente, que la lluvia dejará de caer.)
A pesar de ello Israel es un país próspero,
un importante exportador agroalimentario y
tiene un suministro abundante y garantizado
de agua. De hecho, incluso les suministra
agua a sus vecinos.
Así que... La pregunta, la gran pregunta
que podemos hacernos es, ¿cómo demonios
han logrado superar la escasez de agua? ¿Qué
podemos aprender de ellos? ¿Nos enfrentamos
a un futuro con agua o con sed?
En este vídeo os vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas pero, antes tenemos que empezar
por el principio. Tenemos que ver un poquito
de historia.
(LAS ARTERIAS DE ISRAEL)
A finales de los años 20, los economistas
que asesoraban al gobierno británico, que
en aquel momento era quien controlaba este
territorio, afirmaron que la inmigración
de más judíos a Palestina no era sostenible.
Y no lo era porque según sus cálculos los
recursos hídricos eran tan limitados que
era imposible que pudieran vivir más de 2
millones de personas tirando por lo alto.
[Sí, lo sé, hoy son más de 12 millones.
Ya sabéis las previsiones]
El caso es que desde ese preciso momento,
las organizaciones judías de la zona entendieron
que su futuro pasaba por incrementar los recursos
hídricos. Tenían que encontrar agua a toda
costa: para los campos de cultivo, para los
nuevos colonos que pudieran llegar y para
poder construir un nuevo Israel.
(Pero había un problema: la mayor parte del
país era desértico, árido y seco. Los recursos
hídricos disponibles se concentraban en el
norte, pero los judíos se estaban estableciendo
mayoritariamente entorno a la nueva gran urbe
de la región, Tel Aviv, situada en el centro
del país.
Así que para resolver este embrollo, tras
la publicación del informe británico en
1939,, le encargaron a uno de los ingenieros
hidráulicos más reputados del país, Simcha
Blass, un inmigrante polaco, que diseñara
un plan hídrico. Ni más ni menos que el
plan que tenía que garantizar el futuro de
Israel.)
Y, ¿Sabéis qué? Dicho y hecho.
Eso fue exactamente lo que hizo. Haciendo
gala de todo su ingenio y atrevimiento, el
señor Blass diseñó un plan de 3º fases,
prácticamente el plan que se ejecutó durante
décadas y que hizo posible el despegue demográfico
y económico de Israel.
Veréis, la primera fase consistía en la
extracción de agua mediante perforaciones
profundas. Simcha Blass estaba convencido
de que bajo el subsuelo de Israel, incluso
en zonas tan áridas como el desierto del
Neguev había agua y se propuso encontrarla
para abastecer nuevos establecimientos agrícolas.
Claro que incluso de tener éxito, esa operación
no sería suficiente. El país tenía que
aprovechar hasta la última gota que hubiera
disponible. Es decir, tenían que conseguir
trasladar el agua desde donde era relativamente
abundante hasta donde hacía falta.
Exactamente por eso, las 2 siguientes fases
respondieron precisamente a esta idea.
(La segunda fase tenía como objetivo bombear
agua desde el rio Jordan, el rio más importante
de la región, hasta el sureste,llegando incluso
hasta el mismísimo desierto del Neguev, una
zona inhabitada en la cual los nuevos colonos
podrían instalarse y hacer crecer sus campos
de cultivo.)
Pero con mucha diferencia la parte más importante
del plan fue la tercera fase: la construcción
del Acueducto Nacional.
Hablamos de un enorme trasvase de más de
100km que tenía que trasladar agua desde
el norte del país, especialmente desde el
mar de Galilea - el lago de agua dulce más
grande del país - hasta donde hiciera falta,
conectando además los recursos desarrollados
en las fases anteriores.
En otras palabras, lo que Simcha Blass propuso
fue un enorme plan de inversión para construir
las arterias de Israel. Esto es, un enorme
sistema hídrico que logrará garantizar el
acceso al agua dulce a lo largo y ancho de
todo el país. Y, ojo, porque si algo estaba
claro es que poner en marcha este plan era
algo urgente. Fijaos.
(El día de la declaración de independencia
del estado hebreo, el 14 de mayo de 1948,
Israel tenía 806 mil habitantes. Prácticamente
en tan sólo en los siguientes 3 años llegaron
al país casi 700 mil personas más. Evidentemente,
la inmensa mayor parte de ellas procedentes
del viejo continente.
Evidentemente, para atender de repente a tantas
personas, alimentarlas y lograr que encontrasen
un trabajo para subsistir hacía falta mucha,
muchísima agua. De esta forma, las restricciones
de agua se volvieron cada vez más exigentes
y poner el plan de Simcha Blass era algo de
máxima urgencia.)
El problema es que hacía falta mucho dinero,
y no estamos hablando de un país precisamente
rico por aquel entonces.
[Por no hablar de que los pocos recursos de
los que disponía el nuevo gobierno israelí,
pues, iban a parar en gran medida a la seguridad
y la defensa.]
Entonces, ¿Cómo hacerlo?
Fue justo aquí cuando el por aquel entonces
Primer Ministro de Israel, Ben Gurion tomó
una de las decisiones más polémicas de la
historia de Israel. Una decisión que pudo
incluso terminar desembocando en todo un conflicto
civil.
(A comienzos de la década de los 50, Ben
Gurion aceptó firmar un acuerdo de reparación
con la República Federal Alemana de Konrad
Adenauer . Un acuerdo por el que el estado
de Israel recibía una indemnización de 3.000
millones de marcos como compensación por
los crímenes nazis y el robo y la destrucción
de propiedades judías durante los tiempos
del III reich.)
Fue algo tremendamente impopular. ¿Aceptar
una compensación por tanto dolor? Muchos
israelíes sintieron que se estaba comprando
su dolor, que se estaba mercantilizando con
uno de los sucesos más trágicos de la historia
de la humanidad.
Hubo protestas, manifestaciones, enfrentamientos
violentos con las fuerzas de seguridad y al
final la Knesset, el parlamento israelí,
aprobó el acuerdo por tan sólo dos votos
de diferencia.
A pesar de todo, ya había dinero. El trasvase
del río Jordán se completó en 1955 y durante
los siguientes años el país se puso patas
arriba. El acueducto nacional supuso construir
tuberías, canales y pequeños embalses por
toda la geografía nacional.
La propia red principal tenía que ser básicamente
subterránea y ser capaz de soportar cualquier
ataque que se pudiera producir.
Trabajaron miles y miles de personas en esta
inmensa obra y el gasto per capita fue mayor
que el del mismísimo Canal de Panamá. Pero
finalmente en 1964 el acueducto nacional fue
una realidad. El suministro de agua estaba
por fin garantizado en todo el país.
Sin esta inmensa obra podemos decir que el
enorme crecimiento económico y demográfico
que Israel ha experimentado no hubiera sido
posible.
Ahora bien, hoy Israel tiene más de 9 millones
de habitantes y una economía moderna. Hacía
falta hacer más.
(ISRAEL NECESITA MÁS AGUA)
Con el comienzo del siglo XXI, los
problemas con el suministro de agua volvieron
a estar sobre la mesa. Y fue aquí cuando
se puso en marcha una nueva revolución.
En 2006 se tomó la decisión de transferir
la gestión del sistema de agua desde el nivel
político al nivel tecnocrático. Esto es,
los políticos dejaron de estar al frente
y se creó la Autoridad del Agua de Israel,
una agencia cuya misión es gestionar el sistema
de manera profesional.
Y vaya si lo hicieron. En 2008 esta Autoridad
del Agua tomó una decisión muy controvertida:
todo el mundo tendría que pagar el precio
real que costaba suministrar el agua.
Hasta ese momento, tal y cómo ocurre en la
mayor parte de países del mundo el precio
del agua estaba subvencionado por el gobierno.
("La gente entiende que el agua es un tesoro,
pero no comprende por qué tiene que pagarla.
Ven la lluvia y creen que el agua es gratis.
Y tienen razón. Ese agua es gratis. Pero
el agua segura, confiable y siempre disponible
no es gratis y no puede serlo. La construcción
de infraestructuras no es gratis". Miembro
de alto rango de la Autoridad del Agua de
Israel.)
La medida tenía dos objetivos muy claros:
por un lado impulsar el ahorro de agua.
Ya sabes, si tienes que pagar más gastas
menos.
Y por otro incrementar los ingresos del sistema
para poder construir más infraestructuras
y mejorar su mantenimiento.
Pero eso no fue todo.
(Esta Agencia también le retiró a los ayuntamientos
el control de la distribución del agua y
la gestión de las aguas residuales. A cambio
creó un sistema de 55 empresas municipales
que tenían que funcionar con criterios de
mercado para gestionar toda la red.
El dinero recaudado ya no iría a los presupuestos
municipales sino a mejorar el sistema, por
ejemplo a evitar las fugas de agua de las
tuberías, que en muchas ciudades supone perder
más del 30% de todo el agua. En Israel está
muy por debajo del 10%. )
Además, de esta forma si un alcalde quiere
regar los parques municipales, pues ya no
tiene agua gratis para hacerlo, tiene que
pagar el precio real.
La medida, amigos, fue un completo y rotundo
éxito.
Sin tener que limitar el suministro, el consumo
de agua residencial pública y privada cayó
casi un 20% en todo el país.
Por ejemplo, en los parques y jardines se
sustituyeron muchas plantas por otras mejor
adaptadas a la zona que consumían menos agua.
Y luego, en la agricultura, pues, pasó tres
cuartas partes de lo mismo.
(Y eso no es todo. Para impulsar la innovación
en materia del agua el gobierno estableció
planes de apoyó a la inversión en innovación
de estas nuevas empresas. La idea era convertir
las ciudades israelíes en auténticos laboratorios
del agua. Las empresas compiten por los fondos
al tiempo que las innovaciones les permiten
mejorar su hoja de resultados.)
Y así, así es cómo se venció de nuevo
a la sequía durante los primeros años de
este siglo. Pero, ¿sabéis qué? Aún no
hemos terminado. Una cosa es evitar la sequía
y otra muy distinta tener todo el agua que
quieras y, además, convertirlo en un gran
negocio. Y eso es exactamente lo que Israel
ha conseguido.
Atentos.
(EN EL INGENIO ESTÁ LA CLAVE)
Israel es un país conocido por 3 cosas: el
Mossad, la eficacia de sus fuerzas armadas
y también por la innovación. De hecho, es
conocido como la Start-up Nation.
Y en el caso de la gestión del agua, que
es toda una prioridad nacional, no iba a ser
diferente. Especialmente en el campo de la
agricultura, que al fin y al cabo supone el
55% de todo el consumo de agua de Israel.
Y fue precisamente en este país donde se
produjo una de las grandes revoluciones agrícolas
de las últimas décadas: el riego por goteo.
Una técnica que permite ahorrar hasta el
60% del agua al tiempo que mejora el rendimiento
de los cultivos.
Hablamos de una técnica que consiste en regar
una planta gota a gota directamente a la raíz
y que en los últimos años ha sido mejorada
con el conocido como fertirriego, esto es
un riego por goteo en el que se incluyen también
gota a gota los fertilizantes.
E incluso con el nutrirriego, el novamás
de la tecnología agrícola.
En este caso, mediante el riego por goteo
se suministra todo lo que las plantas necesitan
para crecer, de tal forma que incluso se pueden
desarrollar enormes plantaciones sobre la
mismísima arena del desierto.
("Con el nutrirriego los cultivos crecen en
cualquier lado. La arena del desierto se puede
utilizar para mantener la planta en su lugar
y el agua con nutrientes es administrada por
el riego por goteo que se encarga del resto"
Rafi Mehoudan)
E incluso ahora están introduciendo diminutos
dispositivos que se colocan en las raíces
y detectan cuando hay que regar exactamente
las plantas.
Pues bien, todas estas tecnologías han sido
desarrolladas sobre todo por empresas israelíes.
Pero ahí no queda todo.
Otro campo en el que los israelíes son especialmente
buenos es en el de las semillas. Tanto de
las tradicionales como de las modificadas
genéticamente. Algo que les ha permitido,
por ejemplo, reducir el consumo de agua de
cada planta.
E Incluso, atentos, han desarrollado semillas
que se pueden regar con agua ligeramente salada
como el agua salobre, que es un tipo de agua
de la que hay gran cantidad en el subsuelo
de todo oriente medio pero, que siempre se
pensó, pues, que no valía para nada.
Sí, sí, tal cual como lo escucháis. En
Israel podéis encontraros con melones, tomates,
pimientos o berenjenas, entre otras muchas
clases de frutas y verduras que son regadas
con una mezcla de agua dulce y agua salada.
Y aún más.
(Junto a la infraestructura ligada al Acueducto
Nacional, durante los últimos años este
país ha desarrollado una segunda infraestructura
para repartir las aguas residuales depuradas
por todo el país, de tal forma que ni más
ni menos que el 85% de todas ellas se reutilizan,
¿Para qué? Pues básicamente para la agricultura
y también para regar parques o campos de
golf, por ejemplo.)
No hay nada parecido en el resto del mundo.
Y para colmo, Israel también se ha convertido
en uno de los líderes mundiales en la tecnología
de la desalinización.
De hecho, una de las mayores plantas por volumen
y eficiencia de todo el mundo se encuentra
precisamente en el entorno de Tel Aviv: la
planta Sorek, que es capaz de procesar más
de 600 millones de litros de agua al día.
Y así, así amigos, es como Israel ha vencido
a las sequías que llevaban azotando esta
región del mundo desde hace milenios. Israel,
un país enclavado en un terreno seco y árido
hoy tiene todo el suministro de agua que puede
necesitar. E incluso le suministra agua a
Palestina y también a Jordania.
Todo lo ha conseguido mediante ingeniería, innovación y, también, muy importante, el uso del sistema de precios.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti,
¿Qué te parece la apuesta de Israel por
el agua? ¿Creés que es el camino a seguir
para evitar una crisis hídrica? Déjanos
tu respuesta en los comentarios y si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante no olvides
darle a like.
Muchas gracias a todos los que nos apoyáis
en Patreon. Espero que este vídeo que vosotros
mismos habéis escogido os haya gustado.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.